I
declare
bankruptcy you taking two yeah um but
one of them is for tiby yeah why don't
you send that to him in Costa ricao um
I'm just going to hand it to him right
now okay weirdo why is that why is that
weird she said she's going to give it to
him right now she's probably going to
because they sit next to each other yeah
they used
to Toby works here again oh can you
imagine oh no you don't know I don't
know what you should probably just
Meander back there take a look see if
he's see if he's back dare
I you know what I'm going to for Old
Time
sake great practical joke Jim got we go
to theend
I'm my no
God no God please no no
no no excuse me everyone
sex now that I have your attention you
don't have our attention money I'm
listening you had me at sex pervert you
have all of our attention just by
screaming anything that's good to
know I just thought you should know that
I was just offered a job with better pay
better benefits and a better title at
Cumberland Mills fantastic and I turned
it down what that would have solved all
my problems out of loyalty to this
company you idiot so I was hoping to be
made assistant regional manager
officially if you left I wouldn't have
to fire anybody but then you wouldn't
have me here big deal oh it would have
worked out so well can you get it back
it's in Maryland you can call can you
call them I can't I I suppose I no they
never really made me an offer anyway why
are you torturing me it it means go up
to the right be right over the bridge
and hook up with 307 a right maybe it's
a shortcut Dwight it say go to the right
it can't mean that there's a lake there
I think it knows where it is going the
machine know Lake stop yelling at me
it's there's no world
here remain calm
did you forget something what happened
to you guys give it
back the gift basket give it back what
is this it's real simple if you don't
appreciate what we do then give us back
our basket maybe you should
leave yeah maybe we should maybe we
should leave come on let's leave but
before we leave my wet friend and I we
going to wait for our cabs on your nice
couches can you call us a cab please I'm
going to oh sorry look my clothes are so
wet wet nice leather oh my shoes are so
muddy all right here you go take it back
it's been open yeah it was mine what's
missing the turtles where are the
turtles where are the turtles come on
guys get out of here where are the
turtles where are they Michael I really
didn't mean help
me I'm sorry I want you to role play
firing me I want you to fire me and I
will take
it oh you want me to be you yes I want
you to be me and I will be Creed oh are
you firing Creed no no no that's just
first thing can't can't then head we
should switch seats in order to yes
that's a good idea all
right excuse
me I'm really sorry but I have to let
you go and it's purely budgetary it's
not
personal I'm going to kill myself wow
I'm going to kill myself and it's your
fault that's an overreaction you know
what now you know how I
feel this was a fake
firing lesson learned good work
everybody very nice so I'm not fired
that's
it and uh
do you have anything to say to me oh yes
I
do you are out of your damn little piz
mind what is wrong with you do you have
any sense at all okay do you have any
idea how to run an office every day you
do something stupider than you did the
day before and I think there's no
possible way he can top that but what do
you do you find a way damn it to top it
you are a professional idiot hey stop it
today of all days shut up they need this
game Jim let us have this stupid little
game all
right oh you startled me my stars my
heart nearly leapt out of my
chest oh my God uh oh my
God fire oh fire oh my goodness what's
the procedure what do we do people the
are dead how did that happen it's out in
the hall no we don't know that the smoke
could be coming through an air do oh my
God okay it's happening everybody stay
calm procedure everyone what's the
procedure stay
calm oh come on it's not real Stanley
don't have a heart no no no no no you
will not die Stanley Stanley you will
not die Stanley Stanley barack's
president you are black sley I'm going
to give him mouth to mouth no no no
don't give him mouth to mouth for that
you going to swallow this T open your
mouth swall don't swallow
it I'm fine leave me
Al oh I got you I got you I'm pulling
you
back Michael dance on go oh that's nice
that's me
okay oh yeah nice we're going to calm
down later I'm oh yeah
[Applause]
PR all right come on get off
[__] clean Techni do that again do that
again I dare
you okay Bre Bre hold it oh you can't
see you can't see one point two points
three
points I win
I eight points n
points stop it no come on Michael open
your mouth no Michael okay I am going to
count down from five five four I'm not
kidding three
2 1 give okay all right here we go you
are going to learn to be more
professional Luke the that's what you're
going to do
Luke what the hell was that question
what about car pooling uh who pays for
the gas we take separate cars okay
question cuz sometimes I drive your car
and you drive mine why would we do that
just for fun no okay question who's the
primary on the fire
Insurance game
over offer revolt Dwight I'm sorry I'm
supposed to meet my doctor here have you
seen him he's a very angry [__] boom
freeze Michael scoon FBI you know you
did boom boom boom yeah you thought you
could get away with your little ruse
didn't you didn't you well you didn't
because I know where you hid the
diamonds I've been on to you and your
little friends for weeks boo
boom I'm not even in the
scene stop not stop there's somebody I'd
like you to meet somebody else who has
been to prison who can tell you what it
is really
like I'm prison
Mike you know why they call me prison
Mike do you really expect us to believe
you're somebody else do you really
expect me to not push you up against the
wall
Beach all right hey hey hey hey that's
just the way we talk in the clink been a
lot of fun talk about prison today but I
am here to scare you you
straight I am here to SC you straight
Michael this is a bad idea what's a bad
idea dressing up as somebody I mean when
has that ever worked for you never Jen
thinks Hunter's very talented you know
what I don't think he's that good at
least he's an artist BFD I'm a
screenwriter and I'm a cam maker but you
don't hear me bragging about it no all
you do is you get me to try to work on
my rich friends for an investment
opportunity man I would love to burn
your candles you burn it you buy it oh
good I'll be your first customer but
you're hardly my
[Music]
first that is a $200 plasma screen TV
you just killed good luck
paying me back on your $0 a year salary
plus benefits
babe